[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today Tiffany
in Gainesville Florida starts this hour
hi Tiffany how are you
hi Dave how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
so my question is um I have been on the
Dave Ramsey plan for about 22 months I'm
coming up on two years I've paid off
about a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in debt wow but I'm good job I
have a little bit of ways to go
um so my question is in this day and
time should I sell my home so
um I have about a hundred and ninety
thousand dollars in equity maybe 210
depending on how it would sell and I
have about two hundred and twenty three
thousand dollars of Consumer Debt that
includes medical bills a forty three
thousand dollar car credit cards and
then some divorce penalties I had so my
question is would that Propel me would
that be a better idea unfortunately
increasing my income anymore isn't an
option right now
um I make about 139 good for you I bring
home about 139.
how long were you married
since I was 16 so 20
too long 24 and a half years and you've
been divorced how long
um
five years six months
so yeah
okay
I'm sorry you went through that uh
sounds like you really scratching and
clawing your way back I'm proud of you
it's a process taking a lot there's no
no training last week but there's no
more areas in the budget I've sold
everything I can sell so my options are
to keep you know scratching forward or
to sell my house and kind of get rid of
the Consumer Debt the unfortunate part
is did you have the house before Mary
before the divorce I didn't I bought it
okay do you have children do my divorce
grown just one okay good okay so do you
like the house
I love the house it's perfect it's a
good would be a good place to even
retire
um
it's just
um I have had to stop paying on three
consumer debts
um once they came I put you should never
do this I'm sure you're gonna cringe as
I was when do a very significant illness
and during chemo I was still very ill
when I kept getting calls you got to pay
this you got to pay this I put it on my
credit cards so I have some credit card
debt but once it came out of the
interest-free period which is about
three months ago I wasn't able to make
the minimum payments
um so I I still paid my regular payment
but obviously it's already negatively
impacted me so I'm scratching at other
alternatives to kind of get back ahead
so those are the you said it was three
credit cards that's the only outstanding
payments right now
yes but you're just struggling to make
the minimum extra yeah okay
um so how were you able to pay off 130
and now you got no margin so that's my
question um
so I cashed out my 401k
um
yes I cashed my 401k because cash
settlement
um 290 000 but I had to make a cash
settlement for my divorce so that I
didn't have to pay alimony
so that's where that came from and had I
known that I was about to
um
come out of our mission and need
chemother treatment and two more
surgeries I obviously would have never
done that but unfortunately
um
you you you get the cards you're dealt
yeah you know so you just do better with
it so how much is your house payment
um 2407. how much is your car payment
712.
how much do you still owe on that car
like if you sold it if you sold it today
would you what would you get for it well
the unfortunate part is I would only get
about 12 000 that's based on Kelly Blue
Book because of the mileage on the
vehicle because unfortunately how did
you turn a 40 000 dead into a twelve
thousand dollar car yeah
yes so unfortunately mileage so mileage
mileage doesn't do that
you must have had negative equity going
in or you got bad information somewhere
did you roll it no I took it you can't
put enough miles on a car to do that
I have a 158 000 that's not enough to do
that
that's what Kelly Blue Book told me
and you owe 45.
oh 43. something somebody's numbers are
wrong somewhere did you have negative
equity another car you rolled into this
one
in the car
interesting I would double just
something humor me and double check that
when you get a chance because that
doesn't feel right it is a lot of miles
but it doesn't seem like that many miles
what's your interest rate
6.6
so that's an actual payoff number not a
TLP total of payments
oh that's likely correct that is my
current balance that reports to my
Credit Karma
uh Credit Karma doesn't count
okay they got Bad Karma so
um no you need to actually call the bank
and find out what your actual payoff is
because that they may be reporting
there's two ways to calculate a subprime
loan this doesn't sound like a subprime
loan they calculate it as an actual
payoff balance or a top total of all
payments remaining which would be much
higher if that's the number then the
actual payoff number is going to be like
30 and then your 12 is wrong still so
you're a lot closer than we thought
that's what I'm thinking is going on
because these numbers don't work there's
no way you get there with this number so
anyway
um what's the least amount that you can
live on because I'm looking at your debt
and I'm looking at what you earn and I'm
like maybe she can be free you know uh
four years I'm looking at and there is
something to be said for
um cutting your budget as much as you
can cut it getting your income as high
up as you can get it and then whatever
that margin is you just have to ride
that horse to the Finish Line like there
is something to be said for that I don't
know that you're there
um here's here's what's going through my
head okay
Cancer and a divorce
Quick Fix with the 401K now Quick Fix
with the house
and you still never address the person
in your mirror because you've had so
much tragedy in so many things there's
so you're so much pain that I want you
to make sure if you sell this house that
you don't that you do address the budget
and that you quit finding ways to find
yourself into this because you use the
word unfortunately like four times to
outline stupid things you had done those
were not unfortunate they were bad
choices you're not stupid but you've
been in a lot of different kinds of pain
in the last five years and I'm sorry I
know you're hurting so I just don't want
to add to your pain so I usually we
usually tell people don't sell the house
if you do to get out of this and I
really wouldn't blame you here
to be out of it and to be free and start
a whole healing campaign in every area
of your life make sure you heal in the
financial area and you live on less than
you make from this point forward and no
more unfortunately
no more
now now you're gonna you're gonna get
control of these control levels you've
got to you don't have a choice now I'm
so sorry for what you've been through
hun